Well, everybody, it's really incredible.
I decide, hey, you know what?
It'd be a great thing to take a break from
dealing with a newborn baby and do a show.
I check out what's been happening at the Trump
riot hearings.
And the big headline is Big, Massive Dumps.
As if that's not what I've already been dealing
with at home.
Incredible, incredible.
Second day in the Trump riot hearings.
Now, of course, many of you are already familiar
with this entire dumps thing.
Dumps?
Yeah, you guys remember that, right?
Big, massive dumps.
Sure.
Well, yesterday at the Trump riot hearings,
they actually played the video.
Big massive dumps.
Trends on Twitter.
After January six Committee Airs Infamous
Trump Interview with Maria BARTIROMO.
Big, massive dumps have gone completely mainstream,
dominating yesterday's second day of the Trump
riot hearings.
And my audience, of course, knows about it.
This is the original.
This was sort of setting the stage for explaining
the different elements of Donald Trump's campaign
to steal the election.
For those who may not remember.
This is that critical moment in American political
history, big, massive dumps.
And what happened if you watched the election?
I was called by the biggest people, people
saying, congratulations, political people.
Congratulations, sir.
You just won the election.
It was 10:00.
And you looked at the numbers and I'm sure
you felt that way.
Sure, this election was over and then they
did dumps.
They call them dumps.
Big, massive dumps in Michigan and Pennsylvania.
Yeah.
And all.
Over.
Okay.
So that is one aspect of all of the not only
unproven but debunked conspiracy theories
about the election.
And we're going to get into more specific
claims that the January six committee did
a really good job of saying, here's the claim.
Here's someone who knows, saying it's bogus.
And this is Republicans mostly presenting
this testimony, which we will get to.
But one other aspect in general of thinking
about the January six riots is, was Trump
a factor in the people that were rioting,
being there, rioting?
In other words, were they there because of
something that Donald Trump said in the January
six committee closed yesterday's hearing with
a video of exactly that of of Trump supporters
saying they were there because of the things
Trump said, including that there were excuse
the term massive dumps.
Take a listen to this.
I know exactly
what's going on
right now.
Fake election.
I think they're going to beat us out of our
vote with countries in office if they happen
to go down.
I voted yes, sir.
I heard it earlier.
We're well, except for.
The can't really trust software, the mini
software all over.
We voted and right in the top right hand corner
of the Dominion.
Voting machine that we used.
There was a wi fi symbol with five bars that.
Most definitely connected, without a doubt.
So they stole that from us twice.
We're not doing it.
We're not taking it.
We're standing up.
We're here.
And whatever happens, we're not.
Out.
Yeah.
More and more.
I know it's just the 200,000 people that weren't.
Even registered voted.
43,000 folks work.
Here from prison for talent.
And you can't sit here and tell them, I don't
want to.
Tell you that what we're doing is right.
What if the election is being stolen?
What is it going to take?
Okay.
So of an individual coughing a lot.
Those are all specific claims being made by
Trump and people around him.
So that's the sort of broader context for
yesterday's hearings.
Let's now get into some of the specific claims